bienvenue dans ce vendée globe 2020 nous
sommes aux sables d'olonne dans ce
reportage vous allez voir les dernières
24 heures du skipper et binoy à louis
burton
regardez
[Musique]
non
oui
[Musique]
mais avant de voir les dernières heures
de louis burton sur ce vendée globe 2020
je vous propose de regarder son aventure
il était parti en novembre dernier
depuis les sables d'olonne
burton a connu de nombreux
rebondissements dans ce vendée globe
2020 dès le premier jour le skipper est
sanctionné d'une pénalité de cinq heures
pour avoir franchi la ligne de départ
deux secondes trop tôt ne savait pas
encore que la victoire pourrait se jouer
dans un mouchoir de poche
on sent très bien passé évidemment mais
on va essayer de se rassurer en visant
le vainqueur à l'échelle d'un vendée
globe c'est pas grand chose
un cafouillage dans le décompte entre
j'avais à l'ordinateur et puis tu
j'entendais à la vhf
mais ce contretemps lui aura permis de
réparer son bateau et être parfaitement
apprêtée pour passer le cap de bonne
espérance
affaibli par de nombreuses avaries sur
sa grande voix le louis burton aura même
frôlé l'abandon nous sommes le 20
décembre le skipper qui n'a pas dormi
depuis deux jours décide de se réfugier
à l'abri des vents forts derrière l'île
macquarie au sud de l'australie
il monte sur son mât effectuer des
réparations en bravant sa peur du vide
c'est le bout du monde
si vous voyez bien le bateau ça ça fait
partie des trucs les plus les plus hard
que j'ai fait de ma vie de navigateurs
système 3 pour en tête demain pour
remplacer le hook à j'espère que vous
apprécierez aussi du plus bas renvoie
donc maintenant on va descendre sans se
casser la figure
on va renvoyer l'arrivée et ont valu
mais pourra tout ça s'ensuit une
magnifique remontée qui restera dans les
annales du vendée globe de la 11e à la
première position en franchissant
l'équateur pour remonter vers les sables
d'olonne dans la dernière ligne droite
il est au coude à coude pour la victoire
avec charlie dalin boris herrmann et
yannick bestaven tout se jouera dans les
dernières heures de la compétition
le skipper et binoy à louis burton
originaire de rambouillet arrivera entre
23h et 1h du matin ici aux sables
d'olonne son frère nelson qui a lui
aussi a grandi dans les yvelines nous
explique les derniers moments de
riverton sur son bateau et surtout dans
quel état d'esprit il est après autant
de jours de compétition je rappelle 80
jours de compétition c'est la fin d'une
aventure incroyable si il ya 90 jours on
nous avait dit que ça allait se passer
comme ça je pense qu'on aurait signé
tout de suite
d'une part parce que
il va terminer devant d'autre part parce
que a priori l'objectif sportif sera
rempli par rapport à ce qu'ils s'étaient
fixé qui était d'être dans le top 5
et puis surtout parce que ça court ça a
été tellement incroyable et parsemé
d'embûches avec le pit stop à macquarie
avec les ennuis qu'il a eue en dans la
descente de l'atlantique à refaire sa
cloison avec la remontée incroyable qui
fait dans la fin de l'indien dans le
pacifique jusqu'à être premier au
passage de l'équateur
il est 20 heures 35 charlie dalin arrive
premier aux sables d'olonne louis burton
peut viser la seconde place au mieux ils
superbe performance selon l'yvelinois
éric bellion participants sur l'épreuve
en 2016 sa course est allé un peu folle
et il est allé dans tous les gros coups
de vent il a il est allé à fond à fond à
fond à fond tout le temps donc je pense
qu'il a fait vraiment une course
extraordinaire
il pensait vraiment être complètement
décroché par rapport au peloton de tête
et pas du tout il arrive dans les
premiers sera peut être le deuxième a
passé la ligne
donc je pense qu'il fait une course mais
remarquable remarquable à tous points
louis burton achevée ce jeudi 28 janvier
un peu après minuit son vendée globe
arrivé en deuxième position sables
d'olonne il se classe finalement
troisième derrière yannick bestaven
arrivé après mais bénéficiaire de 10h15
de compensation et charlie dalin boris
herrmann son concurrent été contraint de
fortement ralentir après avoir heurté un
bateau de pêche quelques heures avant
son arrivée un tour du monde en
solitaire bouclé en 80 jours 10 heures
25 minutes et 12 secondes louis burton
achève ainsi son deuxième vendée globe
en trois participations en sept jours de
moins que lors de la précédente édition
en 2016 c'est une histoire sur une
dizaine d'années qui s'écrit avec avec
une équipe qui s'écrit avec un
partenaire avec des sponsors est arrivé
couper cette ligne en deuxième place
alors offrir ça c'est une grande joie
pour moi une grande satisfaction et puis
personnellement une grande fierté
ce qu'il a fallu aller la chercher du
début à la fin cette place le bateau un
bureau vallée de et bien à qui louis
burton est lui bien sûr terre rendez
vous dans quatre ans louis burton
devrait participer à nouveau à cet
everest des mers
rendez vous dans quatre ans et peut-être
avec une victoire au bout